our next speaker is a repeat speaker
this might actually be like a bit of a
sequel to last year's talk
and
in her previous life
she wanted to be an historian
which is a pretty cool job in itself
but something i discovered about her
last year and i introduced her this way
last year is that she went from being
like a closed source expert like writing
books about closed source software to
being this huge open source advocate and
i see i think that's a really nice
journey going going from close source to
open source and embracing this open
source community and the talk today is
partly about getting open source into
big government so i am super excited
about
the speaker about the journey about
everything everyone please welcome for a
second time at these conferences wendy
i thank you for inviting me back i guess
i must have done
at least an okay job last year since um
you know jared asked me back
for this conference so i'm very happy to
happy to be here to talk to you about
uh my continuing journey
as an advocate for um using r at a us
government agency
and in particular my goal has been to
get
approval for us to use r
in what we call production
so here's the game plan from my talk
today i'm going to
sort of talk about the beginning of the
journey so some of this will be um
a repeat of what i talked about last
year
uh but then i'm going to let you know
where we are today
uh and i have to say i i at first i was
going to say this was my end game i
guess that i reached the end but i
really haven't reached the end yet as
you'll see
at the end of the talk
so a little bit about who i am uh
education wise i have
uh degrees in various um different
disciplines so i have a bachelor's
degree i have had a double major in math
and physics went on to become an
engineer
and then i got my phd in computational
sciences in informatics with an emphasis
on computational statistics
which if you look back at the
curriculum i had uh this was back in the
early or the mid 90s was really what we
would call today data science
and during a lot of that time i was also
working in the department of defense
so i had
probably over 25 years in the defense
department
and then i moved to the bureau of labor
statistics
which is sort of the world of surveys
and what they call official statistics
so i kind of have experience in both
sides of the government
and
i really did start using um r when i was
working on my phd
so um
you know i have a lot of experience with
our
across the federal government
right now as i said i'm working at the
bureau of labor statistics this is our
building if we weren't working remotely
this is where i would be
this is the uh postal square building
that's right across from union station
and that door you see next to the tree
is for the
smithsonian museum the postal museum so
once things
open up a bit more i'd encourage you to
go there
it's a beautiful place to visit
i want to give you a little bit of
background about the
principal
federal statistical agencies because
this has a bearing on
um
you know the the hurdles and things that
we've had to overcome in order to
use open source software such as r
so there's 13 principal federal
statistical agencies
and these
encompass a lot of different areas as
you see here so crime statistics
economics labor transportation
demographics energy
and more so in the united states we have
a decentralized
statistical system unlike some other
countries where
it's one national statistical office
so what's key here is that uh these
agencies we are responsible for
producing
certain official statistics
uh in particular uh there's what we call
principal federal economic indicators
uh these are what bls produces
and the three down here at the bottom uh
are some of the ones that we produce
and i'm sure you know are familiar with
most of uh or at least two of these
one is the employment numbers or the
employment situation
that's published
every month as sometimes known as the
jobs report
and of course the consumer price index
so as you could maybe imagine
getting these
these data published the statistics out
there
is uh vital and you know we have to do
it by law and a lot of people
around the world look for look for these
numbers
so former commissioner of the uh bureau
of labor statistics dr erica groshan
kind of developed this this acronym and
i really love it because it describes
the heart of
what federal statistical agencies are
all about
and i want to talk about this a bit here
because
at least three of these i think are
relevant
um
or i guess i should say what we use
for software or our it
is
really critical to make sure we
achieve these priorities and first of
all we have to get it right what we
produce has to be accurate
also timely you know we have to what we
use in terms of i.t has to be um
stable because we can't afford for
things to uh fall apart and then
you know we have to tell the public
sorry we can't publish the the jobs
report because you know something
happened with our with our software
and it has to be accessible so this has
to do with how do we disseminate
uh visualize what have you the the data
and the statistics that we publish
a little bit about the rocky road um and
this is the rocky road to getting r
approved for production at the bureau of
labor statistics
as i said i started at the bls about 10
years ago
and when i got to bls it r was being
used by a small group of people
uh mostly for research purposes
but when i got to bls i soon became an
advocate for r and in particular
um
using our for to be sort of innovative
to develop innovative applications and
approaches and then use those
in producing
our um statistics and our data
now bls we do have a system that allows
us to
um
request that we be able to install
software
for the purposes of either research or
production
and uh
and so at one point when i first got to
bls i started going through the
kind of the wickets to the process to
get it approved for for production
and you can see this um
this graphic right here my co-author
brandon cop
went back through our approval system
and looked at
the approval history for r starting in
2015 which is kind of when i started
this
this whole uh this whole process
now the blue bars are
approvals for research purposes the
green bars were approvals for production
so you can see uh right from the
beginning here in 2015 or so it was
approved for production
of uh and then all of a sudden somebody
said in our it oh wait that's that's not
good we have to you know take that back
and you can only use it for research
then again
production
no and then just research purposes
so what's what i
what's just kind of interesting to me
here is it's sort of an indication of
this kind of circular
road
for getting r approved for production
that i've gone through
uh over the years
and this was a graphic that i showed in
my talk last year so it hasn't been
updated uh
yet
why should we use our uh at the bureau
of labor statistics or in the federal
government
uh well first of all you know the cost
the uh
then there's the fact that you know when
somebody say a researcher develops a new
methodology
oftentimes they
write an r package or something or
functions to to implement that implement
that methodology
and
so
that is available right away for
researchers let's say a bls to use
uh in in um
producing
what we do at bls
uh which is and then often the that type
of functionality is
sometimes
not ever available in commercial
software
but in any case it takes a long time for
it to be implemented and say something
like sas
we've also faced with hiring uh people
right out of school
and usually in their
universities they don't know they don't
learn sas but they might use oftentimes
they learn r or say python or something
else so they come to bls and they're
told oh you can't use
what you used in school you have to go
and learn something like sas which
doesn't have maybe the functionality
that you need
so this leads to issues with employee
retention so we've uh
hired data scientists they come in
they're all excited
and then they're told oh you can't use r
or python you have to use against
something like sas or some other
software so they get kind of frustrated
uh and they leave and of course here we
ask them to be we want them there so
that they could be innovative and you
know kind of help us modernize
and in order to do that we really need
to have
the use of these tools
what were some of the issues that
our it and upper management
brought up when we were trying to get
our approved for production use
always there's the issue of security and
protecting um data
there was a
confusion about
what does it actually mean to use
our or anything really for production
and as i said we have researchers who
are you know using r to develop
new and innovative methods and so
there our researchers need to have the
ability to kind of install packages
as they want to and as they need to
and so that kind of made our it folks
uncomfortable because sometimes
you know you write something for
that uses a previous version of r or a
package and then there's updates and
then things get broken so there has to
be some stability
uh
this is the government they do like to
have commercial support they want to be
able to
um call a help desk and and and get some
help fixing something remember i said
one one of those priorities was we have
to be timely we can't be late
producing our statistics so uh you know
we have to be able to get help uh when
we need it and then one thing that was
so remember the
it's the researchers not not the i.t
people who are developing these new
methods they're the ones kind of being
innovative
and so the
what happens is the it folks they say
well what happens when the developer the
innovator leaves uh the bureau who is
going to take care of that who's going
to maintain that um
that app or that that package
uh so what i what i always push back
there say well you have a programmers in
the it department who they don't stay
there forever
uh you know maintaining the same uh
program so there has to be ways to to
kind of mitigate that risk
where are we now uh in this journey
uh i really like this little road sign
up here because i think it
it
kind of exemplifies what what i've gone
through over these these past uh many
years
and you know kind of twists and turns
and detours and
circles and kind of three steps forward
and two steps back
uh but we have made some progress that
i'm i'm happy to happy to report
so uh we're actually ready to um in 2018
late 2018 were ready to
get approval from our executives to use
r for production we had
a way to govern uh the use of r
and they pushed back and said well we
want to have a process
to approve any software for production
so not just r
so things like you know matlab or python
or it's a commercial or open source what
any kind of software
so a team worked on an application
process
in 2019 december 2019 we presented it to
our executives and
um that was an epic failure
the they they kind of hated it
there's a lot of misunderstandings about
you know where we were coming from
and so uh early
2020 i was ready to just you know throw
in the towel i um
i just kind of lost i guess motivation
or something but
fortunately cooler heads prevailed and
our
deputy commissioner came to me and said
well i think we should have a smaller
group to
uh you know take your process
and fill it out
as if you were going to get r approved
for production
so we did that and uh we had some some
good support and it was a smaller group
which i think really helped
so we uh instead of
going back to the executives and saying
okay here's our application for r
they we said let's form a little smaller
group where the members have
sort of the authority the
decision-making authority to approve r
for production
and so that's what we did and as of last
year in december when i i spoke at this
conference we we didn't have a decision
yet so it was still
you know up in the air
but i'm happy to report since then uh
it's now approved
uh so this is a picture kind of of i
guess my inner child i'm at the top of
the rocky stairs
uh you know and and uh i've got my my
arms up in victory saying yes it is
approved so i'm happy to say that r
is officially approved for the use in
production at the bureau of labor
statistics
and i want to say that
i think
and maybe another agency could disagree
but
i think bls is is the first agency
principal federal statistical agency
to to do this in
an official way
um
so uh here is uh sort of the continuing
journey we're not we're not totally
there yet because
there's a lot of things we need to do to
make sure we're using our
uh properly uh for production use so we
did set up a governing board
and this
board was uh
chartered to develop an infrastructure
to
implement processes and procedures to
use our production
and so some of the things that we've
been working on so far this year
is to
find out across the bureau what how are
the program offices using r for
production because
even though we didn't have sort of an
official
approval to use it for production people
were
developing programs and applications
that really did fit this definition up
here as
production software
um
we uh the board also
listed various risks and issues we
needed to consider and
uh developed a mitigation strategy for
those
and we're uh
also trying to determine how can we
uh
sort of find a
version of r that would be used for
if somebody's going to develop something
for use in production this would be the
the version of r that they would have to
use including packages
so ways that we could manage that
uh process with respect to validating
upgrading
and so on and we are researching various
tools to to help us with that
um my colleague brandon wrote this um
for the board on behalf of the board
wrote this paper
on the 10 principles for using rn
production at bls and it's really uh
very interesting and a nice paper
and i just want to point out some of
these that we've been working on uh
focusing on lately which is to
kind of centralize if you would these
these applications so get them off of
individual computers
the version control i've already talked
about we've discussed various style
guides that we might use
and of course the importance of
documenting uh your work
so i'd like to acknowledge um the
members of the governing board we have
members from all our program offices as
well as our i.t department
so these aren't my only friends uh that
i've had along the way on this journey
uh there's another one that i mentioned
last year the interagency r users group
this was a grassroots group that we
formed in 2015
we have no official standing
or sponsorship which i personally think
is great we just come together because
we want to
you know share
we have members from
many use agencies and also the
department of defense
uh and we've just been recently joined
uh
by our colleagues in stat canada which
is uh really exciting
and it was through some of my uh
strong supporters on this interagency r
users group that we got connected with
joe reichert at the our consortium and
he has just been
a fantastic friend and colleague and
he's been so patient with me as we
uh
kind of forge a way ahead
and and it's through
his support and and others that we've
established a group a new users group
under the sponsorship of the our
consortium called our governs
and this is our github site
we also have a meetup
account and we're just getting
established okay so um
we don't have you know we're just
kind of trying to put it all together uh
here
and
just to note that our guppies is open to
everybody we really look for
international members
um and just anybody who's interested in
uh you know r used in either the
government or with official statistics
or
you know government data or what have
you
uh the interagency our users group is
still going to continue
and we think that group will
be more government folks because
the
this group will maybe wrestle with
issues
that would
only be of interest say to somebody
who's uh you know a good government
employee
so you know how do we get through the
the it regulations and and that type of
thing
uh so we're really trying to solicit
ideas for our buddies uh we haven't had
a meeting yet our first one we're going
to try to have in january
and hopefully that one will
kind of solicit ideas for
what we might do in the future
we're hoping that uh local groups of our
governs can form local meaning
geographically or maybe by areas of
interest
and we're uh thinking about uh maybe
having the our guvies
sort of sponsor if you would on our
consortium working group
and some of the ideas for that
are listed here
so i hope you get involved uh feel free
to contact me for information on any of
these
um things our govies the interagency our
users group or even just our bls efforts
using r